All right, folks, welcome back.
This is our 25th episode of the free YouTube ICT mentorship for 2022, and I want to open
this video up with a very brief monologue, okay?
All right, some of you were trying to scrub the video, get past this part, but bear with
me just for a few moments, please.
I want you to think about how I opened this mentorship up, how I promised certain things.
I said you would learn specific logic that would repeat, that it would be algorithmic,
it would look similar each time it does it, there would be specific rules implied that
you would have to follow.
And I taught on the basis of time and price.
So there's going to be things that obviously repeat with those themes, but I want you to
go into tonight's lesson with those promises in the forefront of your mind.
Is what I'm teaching and has what I've been teaching exactly what I promised?
Are you seeing it in the chart yourself?
Now, I'm not asking for a show of hands how many of you are profitable trading with live
funds.
That's not what I'm saying here.
None of you should be trading with live funds with this.
You're all still learning it.
I'm reading some of the comments and some people are raising their hand up saying, I
just killed it today using what you taught, made this much money, blah, blah, blah.
I don't want you doing that.
Because what you're doing is you're rushing in because you have a sugar rush, you have
a high right now.
Because you're seeing things that make sense to you, it resonates with you and that's great.
But don't be in a hurry to get out there and try to make money yet.
There's things like you'll see tonight that will help you still when you think you already
learned it.
You haven't.
And this is for the folks that are commenting in my videos saying that there are other people
that will teach what I'm teaching better and to the point.
Nobody knows what I'm teaching.
I'm teaching this for the first time.
You don't know the details behind what it is I'm teaching.
You don't know how far I'm going to take it and most of these guys don't even really trade.
So they sound like smart geniuses after the fact with market replay or old data and they
have my vocabulary.
What I do is I call it before it happens.
I outline it and why it should happen because that's proof of understanding the logic.
That's understanding the algorithm.
I'm not implementing like off.
I'm not putting anything in here with supply and demand and Mr. Chris Laurie can come here
and tell me if I'm teaching or trading anything like him because I promise you none of this
is found in his stuff.
Period.
So when you see folks say this person teaches ICT better than ICT or more to the point,
really what they're saying is they truncate the concepts down to demonstrating hindsight.
So that way it makes them able to sell courses to the neophytes.
Notice I'm not selling you anything.
I have already made millions of dollars.
I don't need to hold my hand out and ask you to pay my bills.
I do this because I love doing it.
I don't have a PayPal.
I don't have a credit card swiper.
I don't have a cash app.
I don't do any of those things.
I do this because I love doing it and I am absolutely loving HannaFX or Hanna4X YouTube
channel because number one it's given me the female perspective and someone I think that
is really trying to make a go of it and I'm not concerned whether she really sticks with
it long term and she may come to the conclusion that this is not worth it for her or it isn't
really jive.
It doesn't matter.
I'm interested in her development.
I'm interested in all of your developments.
Obviously I can't follow every single person that follows me on YouTube and some of you
may be feeling slighted like why did you pick her and not my channel.
Please don't look at it that way.
I'm saying it from a father's perspective because I look at all of you like my children
even those that are older than me.
I try to teach you with the mindset that someone that has been through this longer than most
of you if not all of you and I don't want to see you get hurt but I also have a daughter
that I'm trying to inspire to do this on her own because I don't want her relying on another
man to feed her, to take care of her and I also want her to be able to break those lines
of feeling comfortable because she's our daughter.
So I'm actively interested in this particular YouTuber for the reason because I have a daughter
that I'm trying to draw affinity with trading through her.
So it may not work but it's just me seeing how another young lady that is inspired to
charts and understand what they're doing why they're doing what they're doing and hopefully
that will inspire my daughter.
Okay so for the folks that are emailing me and saying hey look can you follow me can
you do this can you do that just understand that it's not my interest to try to you know
sprinkle myself over everyone's channel because I think for the most part when I make an appearance
in their comment section it's just like a rush of people coming in and like high-fiving
me and praising me in their comment section I don't like that I don't want to do that.
If you all would just refrain from doing it I'd probably comment more on other people's
channels but I think it's rude okay I don't think it's appropriate and to those that I
have made an appearance in their comment section and my friends and associates and students
that have come behind and created like a circus environment around it I apologize because
that's not what I'm showing up for I'm going there because either I watched your video
I felt that you gave something that was useful to the community or I just liked it so there's
that.
So with all that let's get into the meat all right so we're looking at the e-mini s&p futures
June 2022 delivery contract price action for the daily chart now before I get into this
please write this in your journal okay put your sandwich down turn the TV off excuse
yourself from your children and your spouse go in another room I promise we're only going
to be here for a couple minutes tonight.
Everything I'm teaching you here works in Forex okay it works in Forex it's not limited
to index futures please stop asking questions in the comment section that are answered if
you just simply paid attention to the videos I've already produced okay maybe some of you
just recently got to this and you came to this video first don't start here go back
to the very first one okay now when we're looking at the daily chart I want you to think
about what it is that I talked about before happening explained in great detail why it
should take place and when the chart looked like this remember I was talking about how
that specific order block was a catalyst for setting up a future move that shouldn't
see the high of that candle pierced in other words that's the most unlikely level that's
being here right here okay price should not go to and through that this is the most unlikely
level to be traded to with a bearish order block now for some of you like oh can you
teach order blocks I've already taught and introduced order blocks for some of you that
are asking about order blocks watch my sniper series okay the scout sniper series it's in his
YouTube channel it's free I introduced the order block there and I'm also teaching more
throughout the other series and specifically in this one now that's not the whole of this
model it's not the secret sauce okay the fair value gap is what I'm trying to teach you to
focus on because that small little area in price action that is the thing that is the easiest if
I were to be asked simply what is it that's the easiest thing for a new trader to sit down and
understand right away that's what this mentorship is this is somebody that has never traded before
that doesn't really know a whole lot about technical analysis this is my introductory version of that
there's a lot of people and Hannah mentioned this before she doesn't believe that my concepts are
for like the neophyte the brand new I went in with that mindset with this teaching series now
obviously I'm not going to teach what a pip is I'm not going to teach you know how to calculate you
know the smallest fluctuation in price because those things can be googled okay those are they're
obvious things that anyone can look up but the basic of basic understanding the time axis down
here on the bottom and the price axis up here and understanding how to find the time frames like
this is a daily chart you can see that right here I work through trading view you may not want to
use training maybe you see our charts maybe you use ninja trader maybe you use trade station too
all those things or TD Ameritrade there's all these different brokers out there but what I
want you to learn through and practice through is trading view okay you don't need to have a
subscription to do what I'm showing you you don't need to pay for anything you'll see ads and it's
okay but the bottom line is is I want you to look at the charts like this then you can segue into
whatever your platform is and work with it there but understand learning the way I'm teaching you
with this medium is the best way of doing it so with that understand that I mentioned that we would
go into this area here not trade to the top of that candle and all this is mentioned in this
mentorship series go back and watch those videos and I mentioned that we would draw down into here
and into here so underneath that low here and these relatively equal lows that's sell side
liquidity what was the framework that led to me telling you that this was a bear shorter block
we're watching that and that could set up a run into our May seasonal tendency now seasonal
tendencies are times in a year where markets or specific asset classes will move generally not
always not a hundred percent of time not absolutely never gonna fail they historically have produced
price swings that follow a seasonal tendency that means they usually happen and one of the things
I like to use as a I guess an analogy would be I live on the East Coast of the United States so
if I live in the East Coast of the United States and I reside in Maryland okay would it be reasonable
for me to expect snow on the 4th of July no what's more likely sunny hot okay so that's the seasonal
influence well that same influence not that specific net that that dramatic obviously but
there are periods in the year where the markets have a tendency to do certain things may tends
to be a month where the market index futures in stocks they generally drop they go down I gave
you that beforehand I explained it to you now I didn't give you the details about it but just
understand going in every single year about the last week or so of April going into the month of
May there's usually a tendency for these markets specifically S&P the NASDAQ the Dow the Russell
that group of markets tends to be weak not all the time but generally if you study go back to
OData you'll see that's true now by itself it doesn't mean really mean much but in the hands
of someone that's initiated with what I'm teaching you it is a roadmap to consistency you can practice
and learn a lot about price action by doing this every single year going through OData and
then you can forward test it going into next year and all the years after but what took place was
we had these relative equal highs I mentioned this they took the buy stops or the buy side
liquidity out who's doing that smart money these individuals that go in and they sell to these
buy stops when it's like this and at the same time when we're entering a period of time where
there's a bearish seasonal tendency that means bearish prices lower expected going into May so
we're seeing a run on liquidity here with this high so it bumps above these highs and then breaks
down then we go into an area I mentioned that's a very shorter block and I said we're gonna aim
for here and then under here and then under here okay so I gave you a perspective beforehand so
that we could study it each day looking for lower prices going in looking for the pattern I taught
you in this mentorship around specific elements of time we had this big move from here down here
we're gonna attack the sell stops or sell side liquidity what took place here smart money sold
to the buy stops so now they're sitting with a net short position how did they get out of that
position they have to buy it back how can they buy it back at a cheaper price guaranteeing them
that they're gonna be buying from lower priced sellers find the sell stops here sell side liquidity
rests below here why are there sell stops below there because traders have models that want to
capture these types of moves and expect things like this high to be taken out before they start
trying to stop us large fund traders not retail Rick that trades on mt4 okay that's not what I'm
talking about but historically you're gonna find out that retail traders are gonna have many times
their stop losses in the same area that large funds will the only difference in the only contrast
between the two is that retail Rick or people that are very small speculators the small traders
liquidity is so minute it's tiny it's irrelevant but that argument is used by people that don't
understand what they're talking about because they'll say what I'm teaching other quote-unquote
institutional traders or other youtubers laugh when they say they look at what I'm teaching they
say it doesn't work or it's nonsense or it's a fallacy these same people aren't going out and
saying how it's a fallacy when I'm calling it before it happens and now when I say things like
that that takes people that want to come in critically and say look he's bragging I'm not
bragging I'm asking you all to come in and investigate the things I'm teaching if they
don't hold up they won't hold up but if they hold up and the things I'm talking about happen before
they happen what does that mean does it mean it's luck no is it leaning on a retail logic no it's
not support and resistance it's not supply and demand I'm trading with factors that are outside
of that so what is it I'm teaching you liquidity I'm showing you that market efficiency paradigm
that I taught early in this series where you are being trained to go into the marketplace and look
at how liquidity that is resting in the market or will be engineered to be there where you want it
above old highs those buy stops are being triggered so smart money can go short they're selling short
to these buy stops and they're gonna buy it back from resting sell stops that are resting below
here sell side liquidity so we're not looking at pattern sake trading we're not looking at
indicators we're not trying to reinvent the wheel rename old retail logic that's flawed and gimmicked
I'm teaching you a whole different perspective on how these markets book they have always booked
like this the advantage is that everything is switched to electronic trading that means it's
much more efficient and faster so me teaching this is not going to change the fact that this
is what goes on okay it will not stop working you will have losing trades if you trade with
funds understand that I have losing trades you're gonna have losing trades but you're
gonna understand why you're wrong you won't beat yourself up about it if you're smart and listen
to what I'm telling you to do and avoid the things that toxic thoughts build but you will
know more specifically the times and locations where these formations are likely to be successful
understand the difference between that it's not promising profitability it's not promising a
hundred percent win rate I'm not promising you a high rate of return because all of you are in
the dry receipt but look at this chart is this not what I outlined before it happened absolutely
this so this is on a daily chart this is answering the folks that say you know I don't want to do
this intraday trading what's your target audience my target audience is whoever wants to listen and
then they're going to take what I'm teaching and scale it to whatever time frame they want to
utilize if they want to be a swing trader this is it this is the model that I showed you right here
just being applied to this time frame if you don't see the logic behind it it's because you're still
early in your stages of development it's okay don't rush it don't be in a hurry to understand
everything and feel like you're you're gonna lose your mind if you don't have it understood
you know in a couple weeks just enjoy the process I'm giving you the logic and I'm showing you where
it's gonna go before it happens when it's applicable I'm not promising to do that I'm not an oracle for
you okay all right so we're looking at this area here where it drops below this old low it does it
here and here on a shallow basis but then we have this real nice decline yesterday one Monday
trading so I want to take you into this right here and kind of like build on the idea of what
liquidity does once it takes out old lows like this what can it do so we're zoomed in on Monday's
trading here here's Friday's trading and I want to take your attention to something I taught way
way way back in 2010 when I was on baby pips and I was contributing to that community and
as a reminder one of the things I taught was study the last three days the open the high the
low and the close in the last three days now for those of you that were part of that community
back then and knew me then it was my laboratory experiment to see if anybody would start seeing
the things that I saw early on in my development because nobody really sat down and said hey ICT
you know look at the open high low and close in the last three days and you're gonna find this
thing okay but if you were doing those types of things nobody not one person came to the
realization of the fair value gap nobody did okay so no one's gonna be able to come out and say oh
yeah I was that guy knows that gap nobody did that okay I shared this fair value gap because
number one it's powerful too it's not gonna stop working and it's unique to everything else out
there and it's very specific where it forms and I give you some criteria on how you can find where
they form also that are not necessarily where you might expect but I'm also going to incorporate
some of the things like rebalancing and then where does this formation form I want to take
your attention into this candle here last Friday's low so if this was Monday go back the last three
days you go here here and here now is there a fair value gap in that no but look what Monday's
trading day it opened extended down and closed near low it was rather large range today okay
great wonderful what do you do with that information go back to the previous days low if you go back
to the previous days low this is going to be important because if you do this the next trading
day which is Tuesday today's production video date the 10th of May 2022 if we open up and
because we're below those relative equal lows on the daily chart and we're below this swing low
also we're now you know in a deep discount we don't try to pick bottoms okay we don't try to
call the long-term lows while markets are bearish try to avoid doing I know it seems like it's
possible because everybody makes videos on YouTube and they write books and they do articles and they
say they did this and say they did that they pick the top they pick the bottom I promise you I
know a lot and I have lost more money more money trying to do that than any other thing you don't
need to do that okay so now think about what this bias has been on these markets what have I stated
publicly you all know I've been bearish right so when you see a big down day like this all the
indicators gonna flash oversold oversold okay I'm not trying to pick a bottom but indicator
followers will look for bullish divergence because they think that they're gonna catch the ultimate
low and they're gonna ride it up when they even if they were lucky to buy the low the chances of
holding it long term not likely so it's a fallacy to try to pursue that don't think like that when
we have a bias collectively as traders I'm not just saying me specifically or my model if any of
you are trading try to avoid trying to pick the tops and the bottoms there's a lot of meat in
between the major turning points and you can afford to be wrong at the end because once you're
wrong it'll be obvious then you can get in sync and go the other way if you have to draw down just
work on getting it back and then work in that middle of the move type idea it serves you well
but I want to take this idea here and we're gonna drop down into a lower time frame after
we see today's price action trade right up in here now this looks like an indecisive day so
if you're looking at a daily chart it can be a little confusing like you know what took place
this is a mixed day they'll call it no no no no no let's go into this formation right here okay
I'm gonna give you some logic now here's the time when we get into the ICT videos that a large
percent of you do not want to do this part you're welcome to obviously not listen but you're gonna
miss the opportunity of learning I want you to look at this price action and this fractal now
what is a fractal fractal is a piece of price action that's doing something that I'm trying
to draw your attention to okay we're studying a very small segment of price action that's a
fractal so if we're looking at this and this is that old low that I extend on the daily chart now
it's being visualized on an hourly time frame so every one of these candles is not a daily candle
which shows the highest high and lowest low daily range it's now an hourly chart where it shows the
highest high and the lowest low of each individual hour interval I want you to think about what you
see here now for those of you that are new don't be discouraged if you don't see what I'm
going to show but pause the video and look for what you can identify from what I've taught you
so far in this mentorship do not rush through this pause it think about what you see and then
unpause the video when you're ready you know who you are you're missing out you should have
paused it all right so let's add some detail first in perspective you want to break your daily
ranges up by the day and I taught that midnight starts to cross over to a new day I don't care
what anybody else tells you this is how the algorithm works it operates on this timeline okay
it's on New York time so at midnight here on Tuesday we start here the opening price is here
if you draw that out in time it goes up it goes down and it comes right back to the close to where
it opened up at midnight and it would get very close to what that daily chart showed that indecisive
candle where it was a lot of wick to the upside a little bit of wick down to the downside a small
little body okay that looks indecisive on that time frame but if you look closer and you start
framing out the things I taught you here is relative equal highs old low what's resting
above relative equal highs by side liquidity what's resting below an old low sell side liquidity
the market runs above at 930 it hits that old low that red line here that old low it hits that
there right at 930 then all of the buy side is purged that means all of these buy stops have now
been drug into the market by their hair kicking and screaming they're in they're caught long or
they've been short and they've been knocked out of their short position either way it doesn't
matter to us we just know that that buy side liquidity is likely to be utilized to set up an
idea for smart money to be short why because the bias is bears we have not changed gears we're
not trying to pick the bottom so if we're doing this like smart money and we're looking at the
market like this and we want to be short up here at this trigger event which we'll look at in a
moment where would you want to offset that short position well you have a nice little short-term
low here so you can take partial below that it hits it beautifully and the previous day's low
and it does that run below that low here just as handsome as it did here so let's go in and use
the logic with this idea of rebalancing Monday's daily range keying off of this level here notice
that the buy side liquidity is ran first this is really important folks if we would have gone
down and took the previous low out then ran up here that to me is not bearish this running above
here at 930 hitting that without having this low taken out that is bearish because it's within
the context of the bias that we're looking for when we're operating in them a bearish bias what
we're essentially saying is the market's going to go up to a premium for one of two reasons run
an old high or highs to take out buy side liquidity so that way smart money can counter party with them
with their short positions they're going to sell to those buy stops then seeking to buy cheaper
sell side liquidity that would be their pool of liquidity to offset distribute their shorts below
here so they're going to sell here at a high price and buy it back at a cheaper price this is not a
random unknown low it's in the marketplace soon as that day closed that low is known to everyone but
the liquidity resting below that is not necessarily a target or utilization for anybody in any other
retail idea that's what I'm trying to shake you by your lapels and say pay attention I'm showing
you how to look at the marketplace like smart money not like white cough this is not white cough
okay it's not sam side and stuff all these things that people like to attribute this is not it this
is mine this is I'm telling you how these markets operate and if it's not happening after I say it
happens or should happen then I'm a fraud it's fake it doesn't hold up but guess what it works
folks look at all the people that are now digging their nose in their charts now with this idea
come on now it's catching fire because it's simplified now and I'm showing you what works
and it's exciting isn't it it's interesting to see these things panning out all the time every
single week every single day and it won't stop the second pool of liquidity is the sell side
so it runs the buy side first with the bearish bias so it's doing what I taught in this
mentorship it goes up to a premium then seeks a discount see that now we're going to drop into
a 15-minute time frame zoom on in and get a little bit more details here and now I have added the
830 time frame here and we have the relative equal highs the market at 830 we're looking for
what to happen the news embargo to lift that means that the algorithm will start seeking
liquidity as early as that time frame now it might wait till 930 and this candle here is 930
notice it hits it right there where we're drawing your attention to because it's rebalancing that
entire Monday range it's going back to the previous day prior to Monday it's all low on
Friday so when you see that it rebalances the big drop on Monday it tricks people in the thinking
that it's made the blow and it's going to keep going up when the only thing it has done is it's
gone up to a logical level on that daily time frame that rebalances all of that sell off on
Monday it's been rebalanced so if you look at the ninth on the 15th time frame this does not look
like it's an imbalance but on the daily candle it's a large down day so all of this movement here
is big in terms of distribution on the downside this is a retracement back up into a logical
level which is Friday's low and it hits it based on the elements that I taught you and it's following
what the logic is that I shared publicly in this series look for relative equal highs at 830 it's
going to start looking for high or highs to run that's these over here how far can it go that's
that Friday low there's your framework this is that Judas swing that fake rally up okay think about
what the daily candle look like before we start dropping down in lower time frames it was a big
wick up and a little bit of a wick down but it was small little body on the candle for Tuesday's
trading but if you look at it from the lens of power three how I teach you the accumulation at
830 use the opening price that's down here draw that out in time the rally should take place above
that hits a logical level I'm teaching you then it creates the pattern that's in the mentorship
fair value gap market structure shift then starts to show displacement and distribution to the
downside attacking a discount array so this is your power three or opens rallies up creates the
high and trades down there's your move power three but it's inside that daily candle that looks
indecisive right so you have to understand what you're looking at relative to time and price when
you do that it takes away all that confusion it provides more clarity we're going to drop
down into a five-minute chart and start building this into a very visual representation of what
you've been learning in this series midnight New York news embargo at 830 is lifted now there
wasn't a whole lot of news this morning admittedly but this still the same logic relative equal highs
at 830 starts the algorithm what's it going to do it's going to run for a premium why because
the bias is bearish it's going to return likely up into that Friday low to rebalance Mondays
trading its bearish candle was being rebalanced and at 930 a.m. the equity market opens that's
what this little manipulation is okay what is 930 that's when you expect this little type of a
move but it begins at 830 so that hour-long interval we're expecting when we're bearish a
run higher to set up shorts now the short can form inside that hour or it could just provide the
leg that sets up the framework that will eventually like I'm going to show you here provide you the
setup so all of it is a matter of studying what the markets providing you it doesn't change the
rules I'm not bending the rules I'm giving you the logic behind when these algorithms do what
they're doing when price starts to spool from 830 up into Fridays low at 930 that's that
manipulation time where they create that little opportunity where it looks like it's going to do
something but it's generally the opposite of what it looks like on the chart the Lord's retail is
going to see that as it's breaking out it's going higher and they're going to buy it and chase it
and then they have their counterparts handed to them and then they just run the daily range
against them to take out the sell side over here okay but I want you to look inside this five minute
run here and notice that this whole area shaded here that's the Judas swing that's the fake rally
in a down move that will be profitable for shorts but at the time retail won't see that they won't
identify it they won't it won't make any sense then they'll be caught off guard but I want you
to go into that range here this right here that is your displacement price swing that right there
that's the leg on a five-minute chart you strip that down and you start going from five four three
two and one until you find your fair guy you got so we're gonna do that now but I'm showing you how
you're gonna put your fib on the high and the low of that for those that don't have the benefit of
going back in hindsight you may be watching this video far in the future I've included it here
set we it's already done for you for for study purposes the 40 44 and a half level is equilibrium
or 50% of the range between the high and the low that run here that dropped down why am I
nuding this because we have this swing low broken here now it could have stopped there and started
to move up and we would use that range from here to here but just kept breaking lower lower lower so
it broke a little this low and what looks like this low here so it was several short-term lows
that were broken nonetheless this is the displacement price like so this price swing here you shade that
while you're learning and then you start breaking that down into lower time frames so right now we're
on the five-minute chart I want to keep this shaded area here one but we're just going to transition
from the five-minute chart down to the four-minute chart so here's the four-minute chart 930 is this
candle here that's your Judas swing at 830 it starts its run this is the algorithmic price run
goes to Fridays low rebalances the entire range on Mondays trading it changes the narrative when
retail traders thinking it's created the low all the bullish diversions they would be seeing on
their indicators and such they're they're screaming to buy and breakout artists are looking at this
break here because they think this is resistance broken now oh it's coming back down to it this is
what is this resistance broken turn support right okay breaks down a little bit okay then starts run
okay well this is one of those instances where it was you went past a little bit but it's still
going to go higher you can you can always read into the price action what retail would be expecting
here but we're looking for something very specific in this shaded area here we're looking for a fair
value gap do you see a fair value gap some of you would say this yeah I didn't know that you read
my mind ICT why not that one what if that what would happen if I went into that and sold short
well first of all if you did that you were not following the rules because from this high down
to that low this is equilibrium we need to get to a premium we don't want to sell in a discount
that's not what we're doing here so we have to get to this level here 40 44 and a half or higher
that's a premium based on that price swing do you understand what I just gave you there like that's
a hard-line rule that if you just follow that it will keep you out of so many ill-fated scenarios
now it's not a hundred percent that you're going to follow that and never take a losing
trade because some of you are asking for that secret recipe like I had that if I had it I
wouldn't give it to you okay so it doesn't exist and I don't have it so on both sides of the fence
just stop looking for that expect to lose money if you're going to trade and you're using my money
you're going to lose money it's a promise I'm guaranteeing you you're always going to run
into a scenario that will eventually lose capital money will be withdrawn from your account it sucks
it's not fun nobody signs up for that they sign up for well if it works in my favor I could make
money I could make enough money to go on vacation each year I could pay my car note those types of
things okay and some of you take it to an extreme where you're going to be rich and you ride around
and charter airplanes and drive around in cars that cost too much money to each their own all I'm
saying is I'm going to teach how to read price okay so let's keep it germane to that so there's
no four-minute fair value gap on the three-minute chart inside this pink shaded area that's the
displacement leg is there a fair value gap you can pause the video here if you want if you need
more time all right for those that are prepared there is no fair value gap here either nothing
to do yet so you drop down into your two-minute chart okay do you see a fair value gap in the
two-minute chart and pause the video if you need more time all right if you're not prepared pause
the video lo and behold the unicorn here's the fair value gap small little imbalance right in
here and we took out the short-term low now some of you might see this if you were watching the
two-minute chart okay say you watch the two-minute chart you saw this short-term low broken here or
maybe this one here and you saw this is this displacement one could argue perhaps it is okay
now I'm going to give you the alternative this is not twisting the rules it's just showing you
the logic of when you put a trade on in your demo account hear that complaints this movement
lower creates that fair value gap yes we have a short-term low to taking out there okay this
entry on this fair value gap if you utilize that where would your stop loss be it would have to be
at least above the candle that creates the fair value gap that's this one here so your stop will
be above here did it hit it no so even if you would have utilized that you're not stopped out
with this run here now you might get scared to death when it running up after it moved in your
favor like this and comes back and retraces but you cannot listen to me folks you cannot open a
trade up like this and put a stop above here and watch it go down here and want to trail your stop
loss real tight you can't do that you have to hold with a certain measure of risk open and this
is what filters out so many people in this industry they can't do this they either rush
to get out of a trade that's marginally profitable because it can't stand it they're making money
and they're so used to seeing it turn against them and stop them out or squeeze them if they
don't use stops and they get out with big losing trades once they start getting marginally profitable
trades they get out prematurely they don't even hold it for the models rules or they trail their
stop loss so tight so quickly it strangles the position it doesn't even give the chance to move
and breathe so how do you do that we're gonna talk a little bit about stop placement now initially
when it opens the trade up the rule is you want to use the candle that creates the fair value gap
that high just above that okay one tick two ticks above that that's sufficient enough if you are
scared and you just want to use a nice handsome ample stop you would use a swing hot here oh
that's a lot of movement so what they have micro account positions that you can trade with so may
not be trading them any trade micros if it requires you that much of a stop to sleep at night okay
knowing that what you're doing isn't going to wreck and ruin you didn't use micros it's five
dollars per point or handle versus fifty dollars per handle on a mini so it's scalable it's it's
something that most people should be able to weather if you can't weather something like that
with a micro then you're really trading isn't you're not prepared to trade you don't have enough
equity and you're underfunded okay and I don't mean that to be talking down to anybody that's just
the real skinny okay a lot of people try to go in here and they want to trade with a hundred
dollar account and you're just asking to fail you really are asking to fail so you can't be
under capitalized but once you place your stop here or here when do you start moving your stop
well you want to see a larger shift in structure when this low is taking out down here then then
you can move your stock down say it was up here then you can move it to here okay or maybe here
why because it's already broke down so it's not going to go down here and come back up here if
it does then you're probably wrong or it's going to consolidate which means it's going to be an
ugly condition to be working with in anyway see the logic there I'm accepting the fact that I'm
probably gonna be wrong if it stops me out but who cares if it does why would I have that opinion
of not caring if it stops me out how many times have you seen this pattern form think about it
over the course of a week how many times does a pattern form it's forming somewhere every day
it's forming everywhere either the London session overnight highs and lows or it's forming in a
New York session I'm teaching the New York session because you have the advantage of knowing what
took place in London that's that's why I'm teaching this does it work in London absolutely
does it work in Asia not that often and that's why I haven't pushed hard for Asia and there's
some of you hey I need to know something in Asia for those ideas and those traders that are really
focused on trading that time frame and because they have businesses or that's just the way they
can trade only it's the time that they can be in front of the charts you want to be trading
again pairs for 4x you want to be trading the New Zealand dollar and Australian dollar they tend to
have a little bit more movement during those periods because that's when their markets start
so you can look for this type of pattern to form there only one through five minute charts in the
Asian session so I gave you that that's as far as I'm gonna go with it I'm not gonna be doing all
kinds of videos about it just know it's one of the most illiquid times for me I'm letting the
market create those periods of the day where a lot of traders are starting early because like
anything else we're really quick to get into something but we rarely ever finish it and
students that come under my wing are really good testimonials about that they'll come in they'll
say I'm gonna stick with this but then they realize it takes a little bit more effort than
they're ready for any quit and trading in general is like that and they think that because in New
Zealand Wellington doesn't really begin today they think and they teach and all these other traders
have to say you know Wellington starts the 24-hour cycle and it does not start the cycle this is how
you know someone doesn't know what they're talking about these algorithms operate on New York time
and it begins at midnight period end of story I don't care whose brother's cousin sister knows
this guy that works at a bank that says ICTs full crap I don't care bring those people here
challenge what I'm showing you here okay show me how this is wrong that's all I'm asking because
I'm doing it I'm proving it and everybody else is seeing it themselves so do you dismiss the
evidence do you ignore it you walk around with blinders on because maybe I'm not the personality
fits what you were hoping for in terms of a mentor I'm being honest and I'm proving it I'm
showing it to you it's repeating why argue why wrestle with it take it be thankful you know and
and do something positive with it so here's what we have we have the whole model identifying a
setup moving back to a rebalance of Monday's prey price range back up to Friday's low hitting
that level there and then creating the setup that's happening at the time elements the same
way I teach it in the series and here it is comes in hits it breaks down pairs up with the
sell-side liquidity smart money sells short here and then adds to it here breaks trades into here
during the lunch hour your limit order if it was used would be filled on the lunch hour and not
around 1230 the only thing about this day that I did not like is I would have rather seen it
deliver this movement here just ahead if not right at 12 o'clock that's the only thing that
did not line up with what I was expecting today I was looking for this candle right here the punch
down and hit that level go through it like it did here and it was just about 27 minutes later so
that's not bad right I mean looking at it like this doesn't this make sense seriously folks in
closing doesn't this logic make sense the market goes up to trick people in the thing that's going
to go higher or not those people that are short making money going down in other words their
orders that protects them or puts them in a new trade going up or out of a short trade that buy
sell liquidity is attacked the algorithm goes up there not because people bought it not because
smart traders work together to get the trades to go up there because of their buying pressure
that's not what this is folks the algorithm goes up there whether there is sufficient volume or
not that's the dividing statement when I say those types of things people that think they
understand these markets people that have made money doing things that have nothing to do with
how these markets book it's hard for them to understand what I'm saying because their
faith-based religion on their system prevents them from seeing the obvious logic that's been
shown here these markets are controlled they're rigged and they're algorithmically driven how
many times do you need to see these things before you can just lay down all the other ideas there's
no reason to buy other people's courses and I know I get flamed for this and then I was going
to invite more trolls I don't care okay you don't need to buy any courses you don't need to be in
anybody else's subscriptions okay teaching rehash stuff what I'm showing you here if you put the
time in learning this you will not need to do anything else period you won't need to worry
about breakers you won't need to worry about mitigation blocks you won't need to worry about
buy side and balance sell side efficiencies none of those things that's also taught in the things
I teach in my private group why why would you want anything more than this this is so easy this is
so easy it doesn't inundate you with so many things and variables that's what's going on right now I'm
gonna be honest with you folks my private group which no one can join anymore is so rich with
things that make it almost impossible for most of the students to pick what they are going to
settle in because everything I show works but they can't settle in on one thing because they're
like a kid in the candy store and because of that they're not really fully engaging with one
specific approach with this listen to the comments we'll read the comments actually some of them
are actually in the comments saying this worked for me and they've been charter members for years
what was it I did what I've trained them to do but they weren't willing to do on their own which
is take what makes sense one pattern one setup applied time and price theories that I teach
around the algorithmic ideas and then look for that one setup and submit to that just that and
make it very very simple that's what this is folks I can do this with a breaker I can do this with
a mitigation block I can do this with a just a stop run on buy stops I can do it with a run on
sell stops I can simplify all this anything I trade with I can do this the same way I can strip
it down to a simple model there's no need to ask me to join my private group folks so please stop
asking in the comment section please stop sending me emails I don't want your money I don't need
your money okay I don't need any of those types of things I want to do what I'm doing here I
enjoyed this I am a teacher at heart I love doing this and the fact that I'm seeing so many people
around the world dive into this and find their own niche in it and it only takes the time to
invest in reading the things I'm showing you in the chart listening to the logic I'm teaching in
the audio commentary and then doing the homework assignments of backtesting and looking at it you
will decide at that moment if this is something that fits you if it doesn't fit you there's no
harm in that I'm not offended by that I have people that paid me this said I just can't make
this work for me and I have other people that are killing it what's the difference personality
and capacity some people can't do it at all some people can do it they just haven't done the proper
things in the right order this is a simplification what I have done here in this series whether you
realize it or not my mentorship group that have paid me some of them were kicking and screaming
because I've done this others majority have been very appreciative because they have used this to
help understand what it is that they should be doing with all the other things I taught now when
I say that it sounds like I'm dangling a carrot oh he's got more secret stuff and this is bad there
is nothing more easier readily made this go out and start doing what I then this okay I swear to
you okay listen folks this is an invitation if you are a private member of my mentorship okay tell
everyone in the comment section that this is something that has been spelled out very simply
and plainly better than any other model that I've done I've done 12 specific trading models in my
private mentorship this one here I stripped down I made it very very simple with the expectation
my daughter would learn it this is the easiest ict application you're ever gonna get I literally
sat down and said how can I take something that my daughter who has no interest whatsoever none how
can I make this so that way she could see it when to expect it when will it form how to figure out
where it should be and what do you do once it forms that's what I've done here is it hard for
some of you it would feel like it is because I'm reading some of the comments and it's because you
haven't spent enough time that's all but I promise you when there's more examples shown and you go
through the videos a few times it'll start to become more clear if you're trying to apply other
things like Bollinger Bands and garbage like that you're not using the model and you're not
gonna get the results that would be otherwise available to you if you just do what I'm telling
you to do and avoid the things I'm telling you to avoid that's it I promise you this if you give
this hmm three months of study serious sleaze rolled up diligently going in every single day
back testing and looking at it and then for at least two or three more months of forward testing
it six months six months with just what I've talked here I am confident I am absolutely confident
that you will have found your model it's simple it's role-based it's visually pleasing to see
because you know what you're looking for it's a specific time pattern with the algorithm so
you're getting in sync with what the algorithm is gonna do just like smart money does okay you
want to be like the composite mean this is what the composite means doing he's not looking at
Mike off schematics and I know that might upset some of you that's not my intent but they're
looking at liquidity like this they're looking at how the markets going to allow them to fleece
the uninitiated that's just the way it works folks you might not like it it might feel unfair so
therefore I don't want to believe this guy he's talking conspiracies okay call whatever you want
call it I call it the market until next time be safe